les pompiers se sont rassemblés à
étampes dans l'essonne à la suite de
l'agression d'un de leurs collègues cela
s'est passé le 14 juillet le pompier se
rendait dans le quartier de guinette
pour éteindre un feu de véhicule
il a été visé par un tir la balle a
traversé le mollet il se trouve que ce
pompier avait déjà été victime
d'agression il ya un an
il ya vu d'ailleurs une série
d'agressions alors à la suite d'autres
rassemblements un protocole
d'intervention avait été signé en
septembre 2019
il prévoyait que les pompiers soient
accompagnés de forces de police ou
encore équipés de caméras or si l'on en
croit les syndicalistes rassemblés
aujourd'hui il n'en fut rien je m'oppose
de les écouter
depuis quelques années les agressions
envers les serpents pied ont augmenté
énormément
donc il ya une dizaine d'années c'était
du verbal là maintenant on en arrive à
des gens blessés et récemment on a tous
vu de l'actualité avec des tirs de
mortiers aussi donc ça c'est l'escaladé
en fait et jusqu'à bâle à un tir de
balle et donc nous aujourd'hui on veut
ça cesse sur tout et si dans
l'éventualité on y est exposé on veut
être protégé on va être protégé que ce
soit avec des moyens matériels ou
d'ardon avec avec les moyens de police
qui travaille avec nous pour nous
encadrer
alors nous aujourd'hui on en a bon plus
que ras-le-bol ce que le terme n'est
plus approprié aujourd'hui on veut que
ça cesse on veut intervenir de manière
sécurisée sur nos interventions
aujourd'hui on n'est pas en mesure de
pouvoir intervenir de manière sécurisée
ça veut dire que on n'est pas
accompagnée par les forces de l'ordre et
le problème c'est que lorsqu'il ya un
feu on doit aller faire une
reconnaissance même si un danger sans
être accompagnés donc aujourd'hui on
veut que déjà ces mesures là soit changé
dans nos procédures
on veut plus de sanctions et clé les
fouteurs de trouble soient sanctionnés
lourdement
parce qu'aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que
rapidement ils sortent dehors ils font
deux trois mois de prison et ils
ressortent dehors et c'est la même chose
en dix ans le nombre d'agressions de
pompiers a été multiplié par dix selon à
des chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur
les pompiers que l'on a rencontrés ont
évoqué à leur quotidien difficile avec
des agressions de plus en plus violente
par exemple il ya peu dans ce même
quartier un agresseur de pompiers
disposer d'une machette
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur est venu au lendemain de
l'agression rendent visite aux pompiers
des tempes
il a prévenu que désormais une plainte
serait systématiquement déposé lorsqu'un
pompier serait agressé dans le cadre
d'une intervention